good morning Millennials good morning
Darren good morning Jackie feels good to
be back it feels so good to have you
here I'm so excited and then I'm gonna
give you tony romo today
okay breaking down our Super Bowl which
is Andy Cohen's baby shower which we
have so much to discuss
yeah I still been floating from it but
that's really top of mind for all the
toasters we've been waiting for you to
join us I know how long I knew as soon
as that happened and like the coverage
that I got like first off I got so many
instagrams being like you deserve a
Pulitzer like this is literally the best
episode of housewives I've ever seen
that was never aired and I was like I
got to go on the toast and talk about
this I was and then you texted me and I
was like oh my god yeah no it worked out
so well yes it did um and we're just so
excited like you guys your questions are
out of control I really I'm gonna get to
each and every single one of them but
we'll get through it we'll get through
it that will more so be towards the end
but like high-level yes just just us how
did this come together okay how long
were people planning for the housewives
bought their own flights correct correct
Bravo did not pay for any of this none
of this was filmed outside of like what
we had on our instagrams basically the
night that Andy had announced that he
was gonna have a baby which was December
20th which was come o G faithful right
feels like our Christmas show with all
of the originals - some people who
couldn't make it that night he made that
announcement - people who might have not
been invited Lisa man around Nene and
Kyle and Ramona and Vicki and Teresa
took it upon themselves to plan it so
considering the fact that it happened
like mid January and we found it a month
before that only a month well planning
happened and Kyle lik invited everyone
she sent out the invites I had
absolutely nothing to do with it was
like a paperless post I was a paperless
post very it was a paperless post and
how did she get all the housewives
emails oh I mean we have a database with
every single one of them I'm not sure
exactly how she had it first up I'm sure
she sent it out to like the head honcho
of each franchise and then they
dispersed accordingly I am and it really
is like a sorority like national chapter
and then you go to like the read the
president of each sorority house exactly
that's it's it's exactly that and you
could just see like like all the little
cliques and how each friend
like represented their own like it's
amazing so which franchise would you say
was MVP uh Atlanta
oh really yeah I would I wouldn't even
say Beverly Hills fight with bears okay
definitely I was like okay they're
always MVP they were in their home turf
you know they Kyle was the one planning
it like they're famous sort of in their
own right but Atlanta has the best
entrance and I feel like when they
walked in they just like turned up
there's six feet tall they're gorgeous
they just have really loud personalities
but in the best way
like even Marcel didn't even really
dress up that was kind of cool there was
a lot and my personal choice for best
dress was Cynthia Bailey
of course the Italian juried garite was
one of my favorites oh really I feel
like a tux okay cuz you know from the
Lisa we're gonna Instagram stories of it
all she looks like she was wearing like
black top and black leggings and a high
pony which like I love meets fashion yes
no so I loved it but I I thought maybe
she was playing it cool but if it was a
tuck it was a tops with like tails like
it was really really cool because I
actually was like maybe juried had some
she was at the aquarium with her kids
like maybe she was coming from somewhere
else yeah that she's oh not Doreen she
turned out and she's just very very thin
so it was just perfect looking but yeah
Cynthia Bailey like rush it Christian
she mean she was looking a yellow suit
like okay that's amazing obsess yeah and
so I think we all are in agreement on
who the MVP was but I guess one here
maybe maybe there's something we didn't
see okay you guys think that Lisa rennet
was the MVP of course yeah I think that
she was the I don't want to say she was
the unexpected MVP because like everyone
expects Lee surrendered to turn out but
I don't think we ever knew how many
touchdowns she was gonna really throw no
I know you know what I mean like I
didn't really she was gonna get the ball
so much and just keep their own a
complete passes and she did she really
did and if I hadn't known this was going
down and yep I could have yet we could
have made predictions like the Super
Bowl like who's gonna win who's gonna be
MVP right I don't know who I would have
said I don't think I would have said
because I feel like Lisa Rinna I love
her mostly because even back in the day
when she was being a [ __ ] starter and
like yeah but with you know how they
thought about her my friend Rebecca
always really liked her so now she just
reminds me of my friend Rebecca and she
just has that sort of spirit so I've
always really liked her but I've always
thought
she was a little underappreciated and
she kind of like agreed gets the short
end of the stick on Beverly Hills but I
feel as though she played it she had a
season of playing it safe yes she did of
course everyone always says a season of
playing it right I never know and some
people like Ramona when she does it like
she hates it
she hates every minute of it she's like
third on the couch every union she's out
I think Lisa Rinna actually enjoyed it
but then I think this season I don't
know what's going down but I think she
saw some great injustice is that she
just couldn't keep quiet about I think
Lisa Rinna has fully come into her own I
mean listen she's famous in her own
right like she was famous before the
Housewives we have Denise Richards
unbelievable thing that I yeah I'm on
the fence about about famous Housewives
but Lisa Rinna has turned me and Eileen
you feel that way about rich housewives
are just famous famous okay love rich
housewives okay famous housewife it kind
of like unfair but I think that Lisa
Rinna was a great person to start with
cuz she's always that like you know up
and down in her and she's not too proud
but I'm curious to see how the Denise
Richards of it all pans out because she
is so famous and will she get down and
dirty well that was the thing too
because I had never met her so like seen
Denise Richards there was a first time
and she was with Rebecca romaine because
Jerry O'Connell was there you know
they're big housewives I was talking to
Jerry the whole time and Jerry's like I
just want Rebecca romaine to get him
fight with one of the Beverly Hills
girls in a boom she's a friend and then
boom she's a housewife like he was
planning everything out which was
hilarious but it was weird seeing two
famous actresses in their own right like
talk at this housewives baby shower what
was also weird was that the baby shower
had like literally nothing to do with
the baby oh like there was like a
photobooth like in the back with like
rattles and like it's a boy but like
other than that like there were no baby
mentions at all which right which is
kind of yeah never say the last hurrah
it's like a bachelorette party yeah baby
and to your point before I wouldn't have
expected Lisa Rinna to be as MVP as she
was I thought it wouldn't might have
been Sonja after a few cocktails
I thought maybe Dorinda who's New
Yorkers like yeah I feel like they had
that close bond with Andy just simply
from proximity yeah that's very true
what I thought but Lisa Rinna she pulled
out all the stops more than all the
stocks yeah okay now just a few more
questions before we table the subject
who were the most unexpected of friends
well I mean Oh like who were getting
along the most yeah that was the like
there were a lot of there was a lot of
crossover I was surprised to see Phaedra
there in her own right agree okay so
having her there I was happy to see her
I love Phaedra she's so nice to me I was
really welcome sign to see her she was
so lovely and like I think I need a Nene
has always like championed her whenever
like who do you want back on he's like I
want Phaedra back on and from what I saw
she was very much so getting along with
everyone so do you think it's a
possibility I I wouldn't I would say
never say never
I really wouldn't I don't know all the
inner like legal stipulation right
because of obviously something went down
that was serious it wasn't just like
she's boring like it clearly had nothing
to do with her back that she's boring
right um so I don't really know the
legal stipulations but I do know that
it's a Never Say Never if it wasn't ever
say never she wouldn't have come right
she wouldn't have come that's my
personal opinion
Marlo always great Danielle Staub it was
a little touch-and-go there because she
wasn't actually originally invited any
think Teresa invited her and she flew
out and you know listen we're not gonna
kick anyone away this isn't like the
most exclusive club ever this is just
like in action I mean it like it is but
like it wasn't and II would never do
right look they're there to celebrate
him you know what I mean and it was a
good thing that she was there but it was
like New York and New Jersey weren't
really getting along and they were like
East Coast and you thought that they
would and it was a all represented there
perfect
stereotypes like Jeana and Emily were
kind of on the side they didn't even
really sit at the table they're only
hanging out with Jen Emily they're so
looking at one of their instagrams you
can't I don't know which one because
Jeana looks like Emily and Emily looks
like a Jeana I know I know now like and
I said that to you the first time about
them and even still I always need a
minute okay no Jeana
Emily I see Gina I was looking at one of
their instagrams and all that person was
supposing I think it was Emily's
Instagram she only post pictures with
Jeana like it's really like yeah at
least a tall one was like yeah the word
husband and Gina's the young one who's
getting divorced yes Jeana and who also
got a DUI which is a story for today yes
okay yes which I haven't even really
read up on so we'll talk about it I will
say that I had never met them before
either and they were also
and really really lovely I just wanted
them to kind of like mix in more cuz I
often as a fan who also works with them
like I often forget that like it is real
life
like the real drama is ensuing I will
say there were a couple fights out
breaking out in Beverly Hills that Andy
told him to button up save it for the
reunion couple of things in OC that were
happening it was a lot that's good so
exciting and now one glaring question
yeah where was Lisa Vanderpump well I
will say we serve Vanderpump Bros day so
Vanderpump was there in spirit um in
spirit she was I think she was
definitely good one Jackie oh I think
she was definitely invited I can't say
for sure exactly why she wasn't there
but I think she was invited okay
and I guess because she wasn't on oh
come oh geez Ville yeah probably because
she only will do watch what happens live
alone and like wouldn't have sat next to
those women and if that's where the idea
started well Brian she put the hosting
committee but she's an OG so what she's
gonna show up like exactly about missing
like one from each franchise for the
most part like there were probably at
like five or six that were missing for
sure and everyone who wasn't there had a
great explanation
100% so Lisa never there was no
explanation and it's literally down the
back from where she well yeah it is like
her kind of like home town that makes it
yeah more glaring like countess's on
tour Bethany had a speaking gig in LA
but still I don't think there's any
Bethany issue no I don't think there's
any I think she had it listen we had a
month to plan it so like a lot of these
songs have speaking engagements and
they're committed before and did
everyone know that it was gonna be like
as big of a deal as no it's where did
everyone think you know oh not everyone
can go yeah I don't think anyone knew it
was I mean even Andy and I like had no
idea what to expect
yeah which probably is just like a few
of the house like I believe there's
gonna be like a seated supper like that
I thought and I was like okay like we'll
have a glasses of Jose and like talk
there were speeches like there be
dancing we had like this guy do beauty
portraits where you could get your
portrait done like on a vinyl of your
choice which was a really nice touch I
know it was at the Palm in Beverly Hills
very very classy food was amazing
decorated to the nines
only really like after the seated dinner
did it like turn and Lisa Rinna got on
the mic and just like handled it
yeah like Kelly Dodd I thought who
wasn't there I thought she was gonna
like take that roll over like an MC cuz
Kelly dog just like has no shame and I
just love her like yeah so real but she
wasn't there so I guess Lisa Rinna kinda
had to like take a final take it over
and for that we are forever grateful
forever grateful
okay I'm gonna table this for a little
bit guys we have to get in to the news
of the day okay
last night was the Super Bowl and it was
super boring sorry there's terrible I
can't really hear it at all and it would
even if it was an incredible game yeah I
wouldn't care so much like I was sitting
there watching football for hours and
that was really hard for me and I was
sitting the kitchen she was so excited
because she loves the Patriots in the
libyans a club football and Zach so I
was trying to get into it but at a
certain point I was like I have to go
home I had a drink for the first time
since dry January and it just made me so
tired because I had wine and it was just
I was so tired and so bored and so I
left at the end of the third quarter
kicking it off with wise I really like
my head is just so tired I wouldn't have
won I I don't even know what what I
would have done differently I was just
tequila soda vodka some and they're like
yeah I guess next time now I know listen
honestly like you could have slept that
was probably the best smartest choice to
make during the Super Bowl it was so
boring yes the worst I hate the Patriots
too sorry everyone like they just played
like [ __ ] and it was just like the best
of the worst anytime that you have a I
mean this was getting sports talk but
any time it's like a game of defense and
it's only about like who can defend
their like end zone or goal you ask it
better it's never interesting no one was
the own a high scoring game like you
want it to be and also I mean the Rams
great I was just in LA for like three
weeks but the Patriots like I'm over you
Tom Brady I'm sorry sorry sorry do you
think of the Saints are pissed because
they actually won that game yeah the ran
showed up and played like garbage yeah
yeah I do think if I was a saint I would
be pissed cuz they didn't get it on a
bad call
which only sucks yeah I'd always sucks
and so maybe the Saints couldn't beat in
the Patriot but anyway I watched for the
halftime show which was also kind of
lame which was also kind of lame I mean
I don't care about maroon 5 me neither
so there's that but like when he started
taking his shirt off granted I know I'm
gay
so I understand I'm wearing rosy colored
glasses with this blank really it's not
you
Adam it's I like tattoos I like tattoos
at least it was interesting to like yeah
I could read those like likes a
newspaper right but like nothing else
was interesting at all about no we know
he took the shirt out I just thought I
was like this is [ __ ] thirsty and
right and then I was like how come he's
allowed to show his nipple and Janet
can't and then I saw that I wasn't the
only person thinking that I was sorry
joking because I guess men's nipples are
okay but we learned that from Instagram
you know in New York City though you're
allowed to walk around topless as a
woman yeah I've actually seen some women
and time do their I love it fighting the
good fight and I'm not saying that my
kiss texture when I'm just saying like
dude embrace it like if men can do it
females should be able to do it's just a
nipple yeah it's just a nipple yeah
Jackie you uncomfortable I know I know
for me the thought of just walking
around like I wouldn't want to do it but
like embrace brave season not because of
the nipple like it's it's just it's more
of the fact that you're not wearing a
bra like just yeah we're right and even
if you're wearing a top of nubrella Kate
it's just a brave move I have certain
type of breasted woman I have no boobs
at all and I still feel like I should
wear a bra cuz it makes me feel so naked
without huh and I don't want my nipple
like running rubbing up against anything
right I know we're really getting to the
heart of this but like embrace the
nipple embrace and not Adaline and Adam
living in embraced his nipples okay so
we're gonna get right into the first
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast because our first
story is about the halftime show so we
can really dig into all the nuances of
this really boring show can I ask you
something before we start did you think
Travis Scott was gonna propose to kind
no as I read that this morning that I
thought that is a thing and I totally
forgot that was supposed to be a thing
everyone I told like enews and badges
were like yeah and if you know Kylie and
Travis at all yeah you know that that
would never happen like there she is so
private she doesn't like attention she's
like really enjoys her privacy in her
and like cherishes it right so she would
never get
eh a national TV that's not and also
like the biggest national TV of them no
the year and that seems like the anti
privacy right and she doesn't like she
could fart and make headlines like she
doesn't mean to do something like this
in order to like drum up sales or get
followers like she against herself right
she's so above it so maybe and then
travel this is our actually not will
talk about it's our first story so
Travis posted an Instagram story after
he went on of her and she's wearing what
looks like to be an engagement ring
first I just would say she's always
wearing what looks to be in an
engagement ring even when she was
reading Tyga she was always wearing an
engagement ring on her ring finger right
by the way she also calls Travis her
husband and he calls her her his wife
yet no one everyone's like are they
engaged um they very well might be
married
yeah they vary my wife might just be
like a like a cute nickname or something
that they do to like obfuscate and
people lie to press all the time right
like people forget that right and they
like they didn't lie about the pregnancy
but they obfuscated that furlong exactly
when all this did Jeff right so even
when the Kardashians when I watch Evans
dime and they were like she's not
married that was where they said it
they're not it's not their place to tell
I feel like they feel comfortable lying
on behalf of a sister if that is what
the sister wants I would do it I was
like I wouldn't you have sisters
wouldn't you do I would lie for a says
yeah me too I would live for my brother
in a second I mean especially because
it's something that really doesn't I
don't want to say it doesn't matter
because it matters but it's not like
it's new it's not like oh they're
running for president it's like it's
whether you're married or you're
pregnant that's not your business to
tell like I didn't tell Andy's baby
story for a long time oh well I'll get
to that yeah okay we'll get to that too
um also it doesn't change anything like
right it finding out a month later like
what that's not gonna move the needle
and they're just protecting their sister
because to be honest with you like
that's where their car dashians like
post their stories like a day or two
late right it's just imagine not having
any privacy like as you said she starts
it's gonna be like a page six story like
they have to do that in order to live
some semblance of like kind of a normal
life I imagine however
yeah as I think about it if they were to
have gotten engaged yesterday I think it
would have been like right as Travis was
about to go on yeah
like he's about to descend up into the
he was wearing a harness he came down
from the sky right yeah and like a flame
ball or something and like she was like
saying bye babe and then if he proposed
like in private like right before he did
the Super Bowl that would have been cute
that would been really cute it's like
there's so much adrenaline and she's not
thinking of anything other than like his
performance and I think she knew he
wasn't gonna her pose on stage and like
I don't think Adam Levine would stand
for that Adam Levine is already sharing
the stage with maroon 4 and two other
acts which is a very selfless thing to
do but also you know someone who
understands that they are not enough of
a presence to carry the show I got his
shirt off like he got the same yeah he
got a little desperate little desperate
so I don't think it was ever even a
consideration that he was gonna propose
on TV what did you think of his style
cuz then I saw a bunch of memes
afterwards that showed like pillowcases
from like a target yeah target yeah that
had the same pattern and I thought his
outfit was like horrendous okay here's
the thing I don't even I don't want
anything about men's fashion and I don't
even notice it like I took a few songs
in for me to like think oh what do I
think about Adam Levine's Alf gotcha
okay and what I thought about is I
thought I didn't even look at the prints
I thought it was very functional because
at first he was wearing pants a jacket
closed then for a next song he opened
his jacket okay that's a second look
yeah then he changed jackets into the
Italians for a bad boy yeah then he took
his jacket off and then he was wearing a
shirt and then he took his shirt off so
he really kind of had six were no
changes for a man so I thought it's kind
of functional each song now we're
getting down to pattern yeah and style
it's pretty funny yeah because I wear
menswear like I genuinely like men where
I feel like men have better clothes than
women in a lot of ways but I don't think
men know what to buy for the most part
I'm just making sort of a generalization
so I like it like it fits my body type
so I really look at like how you could
always tell like a like a really crappy
suit on a guy looks like really baggy
jeans oh the wrong shoes I just say you
can so see it so I always look at men's
style cuz I also feel like people don't
do that enough know um and I thought his
outfit was like horrendous what would
you rather have seen him in all black or
I don't know like yeah and if it was
just like it was an Adidas jumpsuit like
Missy misdemeanor like tearaway pants I
would have been so into that
all right like do you the truth is is
like he's an objectively attractive guy
so I guess it doesn't really matter what
he's wearing
well like I care like a real halftime
show like why are you wearing the worst
print shirt I've ever seen in my entire
life
and it was just like a wife beater yeah
lack of a better a great less offensive
term yeah right right like a yeah
exactly like what a tank a gray t-shirt
would have been miles better agreed
except I did like those jackets they put
on the at Gillian's
yeah I like that I love that look I like
that look I like athleisure I just hated
that print top I just thought it was
like well what's a couch cushion or
whatever pillow
yeah yeah yeah yes so funny okay so
first up Kylie even though we kind of
already did this Kylie Jenner and stormy
web search here on Travis Scott at the
Super Bowl after pregnancy comments oh
right she also posted a picture the day
before the Super Bowl of her and Travis
saying baby hashtag number two question
mark so everyone's like oh my god oh I
saw that right and then yeah I think
comments by celeb said something and she
was like I'm just calling him like my
baby yeah it's my number two baby not
right yeah yeah although she's asking
for it she would hide and play insight
though yeah you know what I mean like
yeah it could easily be said that it's
like I'm just calling him my baby cuz I
call my girlfriend my baby - I'll just
break a baby but maybe she is pregnant
and they're just hiding it I don't know
Jackie I don't know I don't know
cuz I wouldn't be I could be swayed
either way me too and I would be happy
either right yeah according to Kylie
Jenner her daughter stormy Webster had a
priceless reaction to Travis Scott Super
Bowl halftime performance the Astroworld
rapper and a house member big boy I did
I say bad boy before no he is a bad boy
he's also big yeah both made brief
appearances during more and five-set the
band's performance included the
Spongebob Squarepants cameo that was
yeah that was weird right I thought that
was funny I I was just like where's he
going I'm unfamiliar with Travis Scott's
work and afterworld so I didn't know
that I if that was like a Travis Scott
thing but I just saw it was funny I
thought it was funny too and I'm not
familiar
either I'm sure there's like a link
there but i was like spongebob like
what's going on that way yeah right no
is it was hilarious
yeah aghast
why're a drumline and even a shirtless
Adam Levine in general one year old
daughter stood in front of the
television bouncing along to the music
in a tie-dye sweatshirt and could be
heard laughing at one point it's a busy
weekend for Scott Jenner and stormy
other than the big event during the
football game the family celebrated
Stormies monumental first birthday the
Kylie cosmetics owner originally planned
on throwing a big party first army but
the rainy weekend in LA derailed her
plans how cute I know that she is like
fantastically wealthy and obviously like
okay got the whole family thing going on
but I could not imagine having a kid at
that age I know that's like because you
are a kid yeah people do it I'm not
saying it's wrong or anything like that
but like oh my god I was just thinking
about that and I was like oh my god
having a child and she's like what eight
years younger than me or something I'm
like oh my lord
it's really cute she's real she is
really so cute about with Amanda said
she wrote about sort of me how like
everyday with her is the best day of her
life I just think I mean her
Kylie's life is so different than the
normal person and I think what you know
she grew up so fast so she's already
guys the end r years and then I think
she also got everything so quickly so
it's really hard to find meaning in the
world when you can just get anything
that you want when you want it it's like
nothing is like special right and I
think stormy has brought so much meaning
to her life and like a love that she you
know something that you can't buy that's
actually a really good point I never
thought about it like that so it makes
so much sense to me that's something
that came from like that's the perfect
normal human reaction anyone would have
that reaction no matter how much money
you have like rubbing your kid and and
feeling this overwhelming sense of
vulnerability my boss is about to go
through it it's like doesn't matter
where you come from how much money you
have how many friends like this is that
purest moment and you're right I think
she's just experiencing that but Wow
having a kid like at that age like she's
got balls like she's she's a responsible
young lady she is well and now it like I
would be sighs if now she starts having
like a lot of kids who can't like a
brood no they're gonna have like six
they love breeding children by you and
she will turn your mom like she she
wants have a lot of kids but like having
I mean having one child is so much
responsibility but having like so many
children I don't know like Kim and Kanye
like just keep churning them out right
now they're creating like their own next
generation of you
like they'll each be an expert in a
field and then yes they'll be the lumen
ami Hey and they're just gonna
repopulate the world into like
Kardashian Island and like boom that's
that's like what we're gearing up for in
18 years like I'm so here for it I know
it's gonna be at the fire festival
except not just cheese sandwiches right
yeah because also at the end of the day
like fire festival like if they could
have [ __ ] figured their [ __ ] out like
it would have been cool you didn't like
were you gonna like go to that no I mean
Zach sent it to us like oh this looks so
cool but we were going to say - it's our
weekend so we never even but like I
thought of you when I watched the
documentary I was like I wonder if they
were if they were planning on going yeah
because I mean if you're not dumb
we're not dumb there are huge music
festival people the separate country
music we love like I have country
festival experience and then it's just
like to be on a beach with like models I
mean that sounds like my personal worst
nightmare yeah no I meant in the music
it's like blink 182 and ja Rule again
not enough to get me on a beach so you
don't care about Coachella or anything
like that no Cuddy and I take hotel ones
because we just we were starting our
show and we were like this will be great
for like work and Shore and it was but
it was torture like like we can't secure
city like just it just like logistics
city like oh you have to be at this
party but then that's like for one
minute and then you go to this party
it's like why can we just enjoy the
party like know what and then the all
the parties during the day which were
like the cool thing and the only thing
that mattered to be at we're also like
work stuff so like you can't actually
enjoy yourself you're just like there to
be there but then the only time you get
to enjoy yourself is that the festival
where it's like [ __ ] sweaty and gross
and even like VIP is there's so many
people and it's like it's not enjoyable
we don't care about the music and it was
like but that party was kind of fun
people were down to have fun but yeah
you really were it's like more hectic
than an actual work day for you guys it
was it's like a parents appearance of
parents and parents it's torture yeah
but we got so much out of it but like oh
my god it was like our worst nightmare
you guys like running around running a
marathon yeah and then everyone changes
in between - and it's like what but I
mean first off it was good like really I
feel very confident about this outfit
this is three days so now I need six
outfits or seven outfits like it was
just like no one could enjoy like the
moment
they were in when like all these parties
are like actually cool but no we're here
to work okay yeah like cool right and
then the actual concert is what's
supposed to be fun it's like no this is
the part that sucks yeah no that's like
the worst part then you have to like
bake out in the Sun and like like stand
in lines yeah right there like pee in
like a hole somewhere I'm like is this
what cool people great and then like I
don't I don't know even at the festival
then we went to Lady Gaga and we're like
having the time of our lives you know
like it's like an actor that we know and
we're living and everyone's like we have
to leave now if we want to get to neon
carnival and we're like but we're having
a good time here right look at with a
half a note so we leave to getting an
carnival then you're just standing in
lines waiting for buses tracking through
the desert to get to this carnival that
sucked like that sucked
and then we're sitting there being like
they're like you can't get out of it no
there's no bus like wait for you like
stay there it was crazy it was it so I
haven't I loved it so right sober diary
yeah like I'm not a fire festival type
I'm not cut out for it
thank God but just I was watching a
beachy documentary have you seen it not
yet so good on my list
I like Avicii I think what happened to
him was really tragic but like not
uncommon and it was what happened like a
year ago yeah yeah yeah it's such a
design that varies but it yeah okay it
also showed me like Daris he was the
whole thing is about how much he was
touring and doing shows there are so
many festivals in this world like
festivals everywhere and if he/she was
doing all of them and so people as much
as it's hard to put on a festival and it
takes a lot of time in working man pyro
it's done all the time also like fire
you guys even like even though your
bullshitter it's like you sold tickets
to sing if I can do it and just I mean
if you but not if you would give
yourself more time but not even that
like the day before it's supposed to go
down and everyone's gonna fly to this
like remote island there's a bill
plaguing it why don't you just cancel it
like now why why go through the entire
thing and make people do all that do you
watch both documentaries I haven't watch
Netflix yet only only Hulu's the reason
I haven't watched Netflix is because
even though I think it's better and
better produced cuz it says like how the
Islanders are really affected which is
horrible but I think it was produced by
Jerry media and they were kind of like
the minutes
wait like the people that like [ __ ]
other people over I don't really like
that
no it's hard to support that agreed and
if you can only watch one documentary
I'd recommend I've watched both so you
can only watch young you got to go hulu
cuz it's more of the facts and it has
billy and it has it has that like right
who's annoying and like frustrating but
at least it has you you're seeing what
people were working with even though I
just about to come answer the questions
it's worth it the only thing the only
redeeming thing about the Netflix one
even though they definitely cut a lot of
corners and the who the one talks about
all the numbers and like how like the
Ponzi scheme of it all like yeah we've
spent like using this money in paper
that and then raising money to cover
this the Netflix one and then the cool
one kind of glazes over what actually
happened once people got there it's like
people got there and they just go into
the media shitstorm the construction
people slept there no I know I'm like I
di owners are like owed hundreds of
thousands of dollars right I tried to
leave transform their eyelid it's
actually quite terrible right yeah so
they do a good job of showing what went
down on the ground like the night that
people slept they're like drunken scared
in like in tents that are wet and like
and it's crazy but the the seasons of
the [ __ ] one is like from the outset
there was no way this was possible like
knowing tickets in December to something
that's happening in April is not
feasible no matter how much money you
have and no they don't have any and you
have no experience the Netflix one is
kind of like we were actually really all
working really hard on this and we were
getting it done and then the night
before it rained and all of our hard
work was right but you're like but it's
like even if hadn't rained you're still
in a tent if there's any cheese
sandwiches I mean like let us say more
like the meme of the cheese sandwich
from that will forever I want that
tattooed on my body note like I just a
entire back - no cheese sandwich I was
talking to my friends cuz we're planning
for Colgate reading it and they were
like you can do this package or this
actually does this one like has meals
included I was like I'm not paying for
meals like I don't want cheese
sandwiches ya know I'm like do you
really want to college me I was like no
yeah but won't it all like no your set
will go on you can handle our meals yes
okay next up Adam Levine post message
following Superbowl performance halftime
show following a controversy filled
Super Bowl halftime performance although
the performance itself worked hard to be
uncontroversial maroon 5 frontman
posted a note on Instagram sharing his
thoughts on the occasion along with a
photo showing the one love light direct
display that took place during the set
Lavigne wrote when we accepted the
responsibility to perform at the Super
Bowl halftime show I took out my pen and
just wrote some of the words that came
to me in that moment eventually made
their way onto the incredible lanterns
that flew high and low tonight we think
the universe for the historic
opportunity to play on the world's
biggest stage we think our fans are
making our dreams possible and we think
our critics are always pushing us to do
better one love the words that followed
were forgive laugh cry smile share live
and dirt embrace remember enlighten
preserve inspire sweat fight Express
give receive elevate climb unify fortify
softened dance scream dream educate
provide inhale exhale preserve I need to
exhale stand me overcome love listen
with the 14-minute long performance
months of will they won't they
speculation was put to rest once
performers were and five along with
guests Travis Scott and Big Boi took the
field so yeah I mean I don't want to
like [ __ ] all over everything cuz it's
really nice it's really sweet but like
how much of like Adam Levine's like
political stance is like being
transformed like the rest of the
audience like live light love receive
give beg whatever like I didn't get any
of that from his performance no like I
didn't get any of it he just was like
shirtless and like feeling himself sure
telling himself and wanting uh to bring
I saw some Atlantean aspects to the show
which I thought was great like the
gospel choir was really cool like his
trading up from Atlanta I have no idea
Google that one but the gospel it was
really cool I like the different sounds
I like that he brought on different acts
and I saw the love I saw up I saw all of
that but I just like don't I don't know
I feel like he was trying to make a
bigger statement that would actually
went down I agree and it's like I think
the performance was the statement ie and
then it seemed he had this thing written
after that he always planned on posting
after the show I guess yeah and so that
he could sort of just nip critics in the
bud but just I don't think it needed an
explanation like Burton the only thing I
need an explanation is the fact that
like it was kind of
and Anna's voiceless I'm like not
exciting but you made their decision to
perform at the halftime show like
[ __ ] stand behind it yeah I'm like
you put in elements that show that like
you want to bring everyone together like
that's good enough
and also he should know that no matter
what like you could do the most perfect
coolest never-before-seen performance
ever in your entire life and people will
still hate on it right there's always
gonna be people who rate on things
another Lady Gaga performance everything
right like you could criticize
everything like right who cares like if
I were him I would do the show and then
not look at my phone for a week yeah
just silence the comments like I don't I
mean he's so famous you should probably
know that if not like some publicist
you're telling that but listen for every
meter out there there's always someone
that loves you don't balances out agreed
however like I think once they made the
choice for moon time not that I'm a huge
maroon 5 fan but I'm pretty ambivalent I
feel like everyone is my friend Dean is
like obsessed with maroon 5 but I don't
think anyone like is obsessed with them
not in a long time so I feel like there
was no way that this was gonna be great
you know they're not like yeah I have
current songs so that's cool but there's
just nothing not exciting about maroon 5
no I feel like they could have I could
have gotten a better contemporary band
that people would have been interested
in I mean with mixed with other acts I
dragged any one person can just carry it
I like the guest appearances in the
surprises like even with Beyonce or Katy
Perry these huge huge names
it's nice having that guest star kind of
come in like yeah I don't think whether
it's a kid or a choir or whatever unless
like you know Lady Gaga that you're
gonna slip that you're gonna crush it
yeah well Lady Gaga's like every
different song is like almost a
different performer cuz it's like she's
reinventing herself as you go right kind
of crazy yeah um and then I was thinking
like who else should do the Super Bowl
halftime show it's like we're running
out of people you know when I got have
like huge acts too but you know what
Lisa Keyes was just asked to you know
host the Grammys and like people forget
about her but she's like a true talent
yeah like I don't think she hasn't as
far as I know done anything like you
know very long time or at least an album
that's like just smashed it although I'm
not really caught up on all my Alicia
Keys knowledge but like she was amazing
and perfect so there are acts that I
think people just genuinely respect that
like you kind of forget about like yeah
I don't think Paul McCartney would have
been bad I know
she cringed at that I don't know I just
watched and I'm like when I said it was
team Carol I feel like I own that as bad
as that I just watch Bohemian Rhapsody
Oh what do you think I really liked it
did you I did I heard buy me Molly did a
really good job
I love Queen but Bryan Singer was the
director so I know for so long I didn't
see it because I am just sitting here
every day yeah
how are people in Hollywood still
working who are predators who are known
predators who are open secret predators
who everyone in the industry knows but
it hasn't come out yet cause Ronan
Farrow hasn't dedicated the time to it
and it's like how do people like that
still work who hurt other people but
yeah and get praised right so ate I ate
have you watched your boy Bernard Kelly
yes okay so it's like that no and every
day 11:11 I make a wish for justice for
all of these victims you like you've got
one heard [ __ ] Ke$ha
how was Ke$ha like still in a battle
with after Luke I was after Luke still
working right so and people forget about
it so what about Ke$ha so then I was
watching daily pop which is my other
favorite mid-morning show and they were
talking about Bryan Singer and Bohemian
Rhapsody and they were saying like it's
so unfair to punish the whole movie
because and I totally had the opposite
stance I was like you guys it'll be okay
if they don't win an award when a
predator worked on the film like it
doesn't a war doesn't [ __ ] matter you
know well I agree with that
so that's how that's always what I
thought and then I was watching and they
were like it's so unfair to like punish
a whole movie people who worked on it
you know the cast the crew the lighting
they we have to talk about the lighting
people yeah you know and like always
gonna mention the lighting people were
so hard on this movie because of and
they're gonna punish it because of the
misdeeds of one person who was fired
from the movie prior to or like halfway
through or something right I don't think
he got all the rights to it or something
right so that made me think about it a
little bit differently I said you know
what I kind of do want to support the
lighting guys maybe I will watch it and
I did hear really good things yeah so I
watched it and I really enjoyed it and
it made me feel like it's rami malek
deserves the Oscar once I was in percent
he did an incredible job and it's like
it's frustrating cuz obviously everyone
in Hollywood knew about Bryan Singer and
the people who worked on the movie I
have to believe they knew about Bryan
Singer but it's like I mean if we know
about Bryan Singer than they have to
know right right because like we're not
victims of hit right now I'm not even in
sure you know I mean I'm barely in the
industry right so I was working with him
and someone was like oh you know like
you oh yeah right but it's it's sad for
them that like it came to an end I'm
their time you know like totally so
whatever like separating the art from
the man you know what I mean like
Picasso was kind of like this known
womanizer but people are like okay but
he made beautiful works of art like one
of my favorite movies of all time is
American beauty and that is Kevin Spacey
in it and like I hate that it has Kevin
Spacey in it but I just love the movie
for itself and like his acting you know
his portrayal in that movie I thought
was great but like I hate Kevin Spacey
yeah you know what I mean but there's
definitely this quarrel of like can I
support something that I know a horrible
person had worked on it yeah and like
are we supporting this type of culture
by supporting the art but but to your
point like there were hundreds of other
people that it worked on that movie that
are like perfectly decent human beings I
just want to create something that's
artful and barely really inspiring like
that's it yeah and if the movie was
mediocre I'd be like yeah [ __ ] it like
it's love loving just for the girls just
as for the girls just for the girls just
for the girls and justice for the boys
justice for the boys justice where the
boys Joseph where the boys because like
[ __ ] justice no I never [ __ ] it's
like are Calot bed and then like what
you say about American Beauty Kevin
Spacey that's how many people feel about
are Kelly it's like oh yeah I'm a dirt
but this is on another level
yeah I appreciate like level I can
appreciate the thinking that like are
Kelly has a good song but like he
deserves to be in jail like Kevin Spacey
I don't think deserves to come back into
the acting world and make money like I
just liked that film but really you know
another actor played it I probably like
her just as much right you know no and
then they were saying on daily pop okay
so if you can separate you know the one
person because you know of the cast crew
and lighting people right should The
Cosby Show still have reruns that's a
really good question
you think that's a really really good
question I don't know I don't really
know the answer to that I don't think
Cosby Show I think it has its place in
history as a all black like family
sitcom that you know the Huxtables were
definitely like a pop culture icon back
in the day and they definitely top
people lessons but I think you can't
really say that without knowing who's
teaching that lesson behind it right I
feel like you have to have the whole
story yeah so I don't think that you can
just say like The Cosby Show shuck sucks
now like I don't think we can make
that assessment but I definitely think
having the whole picture is very very
important right story just like the dad
from seventh heaven uh I know which was
so Airy cuz I was like oh my god please
write me up in heaven where like you
couldn't even like kiss someone it's
like so cold and I watch that show and
I'm like not that type of person at all
like I don't care about that stuff at
all like and that's just I mean
everything is just like so ironic and
like so fascinating so ironic alanis
MRSA to write a sequel isn't ironic when
a reverend is it child molester - more
social just write more and more stuff
agree yeah um okay okay so I think
that's all of our thoughts on the Super
Bowl Oh what do you think of the
commercials I didn't catch all of them
cuz I was flying back from a wedding so
I missed like half of it okay um I
thought the ones that I saw were like
pretty good they played it safe I don't
remember any like super controversial
one I was gonna check on the internet
today to see like what the main ones
were right or what people were saying
the best ones were I love ya Michael
Buble one yeah with the bubbly sector I
like that one a lot
okay davin yeah I was laughing so hard
writing the e at the end like signing I
thought that I liked him I thought that
was really key I thought that was cute -
that was actually one of the most more
memorable ones that I've seen and then
the Verizon one about the first
responders and how important it is like
there was someone I think he meant oh
and the NFL one but there was a guy I
think he might be like an NFL legend or
something and he was involved in an
accident he was talking about it - like
all these like firefighters and police
officers and then they all those the
firefighters and police officers were
like we were the ones who were the first
responders during your argument and then
he was like so emotional and then the
message was just like you know
connecting you like connecting your
calls and the most dire moment cries
love the ones that like hit you do your
core and you don't think they're gonna
be like a Verizon commercial you're like
oh this is gonna be for like health care
yeah and then they totally flip it on
you and you're like oh like really key
I've cried a JC Penney commercials
before like and I know I'm gonna say
anything you to blank and you're gonna
tell me if you don't cry it this was
like it was a Mother's Day one years ago
and like just tugs at your heartstrings
I will and then like t-mobile was like
ripping off memes like the one
the uber driver works like hi Darren I'm
here for you and they were like thank
you so much like it's been a really hard
time it's like no it's your driver but
like Instagram yeah I was it was
culturally relevant I mean usually it's
like award shows like there's so long
there's so much to see that usually the
next day it's just so much easier to
watch like the highlights yeah I don't
care about any of the in-between like
give me the best jokes show me the worst
one and like that's all I need the NFL
had a commercial for NFL 100 whatever
that is and it was the best thing I've
ever seen and I didn't even I didn't
even know what I was who I was looking
at but I like recognize some faces and
it was like it was like it was this baby
shower of commercials it was every
player from like all years old young you
know the best writers and they were
playing like football at this like fancy
dinner it was so funny that's right it
was really really funny there was no
Lisa Rinna on tables so today there I
couldn't really compare to the baby
shower but it was up there it was like
it was up there yes they just needed a
little Lisa Rinna yeah who doesn't
they had that like girl who catches the
ball should've been Lisa R yeah that
would have been so timely it's likely
Eileen ish but so timely no have been
great okay speaking of yep Bravo work
universe and I think the rest of our
stories are pretty Bravo centric Real
Housewives of Orange County star Gina
Gershon Haider arrested for a DUI Real
Housewives of OC star Gina Christian
Haider was busted for driving under the
influence
she was arrested by OC Sheriff's
Department at 3:43 a.m. on Friday the
blast reports cops took her to her Sante
to the Santa Ana California Jail where a
clerk confirmed to pay chicks she was
released later Friday she's set to
appear in court on February 28th we're
told it is unclear for arrest will be
addressed on season 14 of Real
Housewives of Orange County as filming a
slated to start next week so then it
should be it should be a court will be
yeah and I sure though they're usually
like if anything like it's in the press
like much like glue and like anything it
hits in the press especially if we're
not filming like they do mention it
right like they mention it Oh baby I
won't do it yes she said I made a very
bad choice the other night after a moms
night out I am stream ly disappointed
myself and regret my actions so
heartedly
I have learned a valuable lesson and
hope to show you all that this one
incident
to find me well I mean listen that's a
that's a perfectly proper statement to
make I mean I have troubles with duis
because it's not just you that you're
hurting like you can really hurt someone
else
yeah and that's why I have such a big
problem with it people do make mistakes
as long as you know you know she this
was like her eighth DUI I feel like we
could make a judgment call right yeah
like everyone does make mistakes let's
see how she handles it it was 343 am
like hopefully a lot of people weren't
on the road no one died her kids weren't
in the car like thank God for all of
that let's just see how she handles it
from now on and hopefully it was just an
honest mistake that she made and it was
just a lack of judgment I agree well
said I didn't know like I hadn't really
right up in the story before we were
talking about it so I didn't know what I
was gonna say but I know people make
mistakes well yeah like okay she buys it
again like then we can say something
right like yeah I feel like we can make
a judgement but like the first time for
anything like I don't know I've done
I've done shitty things before yeah I
wonder what her her blood alcohol was
wait cuz maybe it wasn't it was like
point oh nine right and which case it's
like oh great
thought she was so like and I don't and
you know like after your one glass of
wine of you being sober for a month
what's your blood alcohol content having
one glass not that you were shit-faced
or you wanted to drive but I don't know
like how that's measured is what I'm
trying to say yeah she could have been
obliterated I'm not defending her but
I'm also not like just casting judgment
to cast judgment agreed and you know I
kind of need more details and I guess
I'll have to watch your Housewives of
Orange County man yes you will yes okay
next story not exactly bravo centric but
has a brother again Pete Davidson and
Kate Beckinsale were spotted leaving a
comedy club that's such hot women I
don't know Oh Pete Davidson Kate
Beckinsale continued to fuel rumors that
they're an item after they were spotted
leaving the Canadian stand-up show
together on Friday night the actress 45
in the SNL star 25 were seen at Largo at
the carnet in Los Angeles where he
played a comedy set Davidson held that
can sails hand as the to exit the club
as she left as they left she tried to
shield her face from the paparazzi their
outing together comes after a page six
exclusively reported that they were
getting cozy at a Golden Globes party
last month now the braava de Bravo of it
all comes in because Bethenny Frankel
made an x-rated comment about Pete
Davidson's
diamond dick quote so Pete Davidson was
engaged to the sexy and talented Ari
grande and there's now dating the beyond
stunning Kate Beckinsale so I guess it's
clear that he shoots diamonds out of his
penis I mean that has to be clear right
I mean like why what I don't under it
okay I think it's just I keep that
micelles like gorgeous right like
objectively just like absolutely pretty
and she's 45 and men usually tend to
mature a little bit slower than women so
I'm curious to see like what he's
bringing to the table to like a 45 year
old like gorgeous beyond her years type
of woman well yeah that's why I think
it's easy to make the assumption that
like literally who's shooting diamonds
out of his penis right cuz I don't I
don't get it at all no I don't get it at
all I think some people find him
attractive he's not my type um then
there's like this whole beauty yes I
know that I'm gonna chat all right like
survive or something like that but yeah
he's at all good he might also be like
really really funny you know and he is a
comedian yeah he's definitely on SNL I
mean he obviously is talented but he
might be like some people some comedians
like you know we're kind of like shy and
quiet and introverted like not like
depressed and like he has mental issues
he may like issues just be making these
women laugh and you know what there's
something to be said for that like
that's my number one quality in a
relationship and no shade like maybe
it's diamonds out of his dick and
laughter which is great and amazing but
for someone who I think also you know
he's suffering with depression he's got
you know he was sober for a while he
talks about killing himself or wanting
to kill himself and people sending hate
mail I you know it's hard because if
you're gonna choose a relationship with
another famous person as well and we
don't know I'm just sort of speculating
yeah well like if you're gonna choose a
relationship with another famous person
like you're gonna be in the spotlight
and I don't think that's necessarily the
best thing for your mental health agree
stay low stay chill like fix yourself
first you know like be an example don't
put yourself up for like any sort of
negative hate what she's just gonna
automatically get yeah I'm easy I kind
of ship it but damn you know I just
wanted to be happy so I would the advice
I know you with anyone I'd be I'd just
be happy for him you know I know I don't
want like Ariana's moved on with herself
and she's doing incredibly well no I
mean like a genuine even the hand tattoo
thing I was like I'm here for it I'm
here I wanna barbeque grill on my hand
dude I've totally
like that she owned up to it cuz a lot
of people like don't although change or
they won't say anything like she was
just like Oh miss you she was like r.i.p
barbecue grill like miss you and i was
like that's so cute like she's got a
good sense of self she's the hasn't
really good sense of humor yes she does
she really does I think that she's kind
of like cool Dickey watching juris Woman
Diaries I did not should I know but
there were just like moments where one
she's kind of annoying and like Chavez
attached or and her baby voice and it's
really [ __ ] annoying but then there
are some more moments where she's just
being like a 25 year old you know being
just cool and I'm like funny yeah I like
that I will say I watched Katy Perry
he's like part of me documentary when it
came out like eight years ago in
theaters me too
with like a bunch of twelve year olds in
fact you were probably there cuz I was
like 25 it's time and he's that like
front row cuz my friend Mike produced it
and so I wanted to see it and I liked
Carrie Katy Perry especially at the time
and I just thought that movie showed how
good she was to her fans and it's really
nice to see that well yeah it was a good
heartfelt movie you could tell that she
really sensed it and that's kind of what
I feel like Ariana really does care
about her fans in that way yeah she
really does I forgot about that movie
yeah I really liked it I thought it was
actually a very well done again my
friend helped produce it so I'm a little
bit biased but I just thought it
portrayed her in a really nice light
yeah I know how hectic her life is right
yeah and then the Russell Brand of it
all yeah there was like kind of cool it
was kind of cool I used to be her number
one fan I loved her I loved her I feel
like her now but I mean her music just
isn't good so it's like hard to still
like love someone like that yeah during
her you know Teenage Dream firework oh
my god I literally would die for her oh
my god when she came out with I kissed a
girl like it spoke to me in many ways
Jack really important my life yeah okay
this last story's little businesses and
I just find so interesting so we'll get
into it and then we'll just go full
Bravo for you guys okay them crypto
exchange says it can't repay a hundred
and million one hundred and ninety
million dollars to clients after the
founder dies with the only password I
saw that Canadian crypto exchange
quadriga CX says it cannot repay most of
190 million dollars in client holdings
after its 30-year old founder Gerald
cotton the only person who knew
passwords to its cold storage
unexpectedly died in India December 2018
coin desk reported on Friday in a sworn
affidavit with the Nova Scotia Supreme
Court widow Jennifer Robertson said that
quadriga CX
owes its customers some 190 million
dollars in both cryptocurrency and fiat
money
Quadra CX has filed for creditor
protection because it says it cannot
access the funds stored in cold storage
just a comparatively smaller amount in a
hot wallet used for transfers coined
escrow that is [ __ ] crazy
I you know normally when I read that
story I was like can't someone just hack
this but I know that cryptocurrency is
actually like you can't do it yeah and I
remember when Bitcoin had like rush to
20 thousand dollars a coin like a year
ago or something everyone was trying to
get it I listened to so many different
stories about people being like yeah I
bought Bitcoin like eight years ago and
I lost the code and so now I have like
20 million dollars in the bank but can't
access it at all that's how they're
making on their money right exactly like
people people buying it but I just think
it's like you don't have like your Wi-Fi
password you know how like sometimes
it's like PQ I like X yeah like this is
the code that people need and you can't
access a hundred and ninety million
dollars that's so I mean the guy a 30
year old founder tragic death obviously
because who dies that young that's it's
got to be horrible but like share your
pet like I put all my passwords like my
iPhone right it's so bad but I do cuz I
don't want to have to like on like half
my self so like he's a founder of this
company someone's gonna try and hack
he's passed like his password needs to
be protected because wait but like you
don't tell your CEO you don't tell your
CFO you don't tell like you're number
two in command that your party's really
slight in your will but then you could
hack a will
but like that's just it's just a it's
just like a perfect story it's a perfect
story it's a perfect yeah yeah so it
that it's just so crazy eat well and it
doesn't relate to Bravo at all no not at
all or anything that you're talking
about but I just thought it was we don't
have any housewives invest now Bitcoin
as far as I know that you know as far as
I know so yeah might've she definitely
lost the password if she invested a bit
no for sure but she's like she's she's
the best
braver than all of us you brought an
intern to the baby shower just one just
one sat at the table guy look at her bag
my question so there were obviously all
housewives there that but then they were
also like the Rebecca Romijn Jerry
O'Connell's yummy what's Phillip
Phillips yep John Mayer stopped by John
of course so there were a few like media
types yeah like media Jason Bravo folks
who got those invites like how what was
the criteria to be a non housewife
invite I think Andy like Andy had some
of his like home friends there too and
like Jerry is such a housewives fan like
even when he came on watching up inside
like he's just this was his moment that
I think Andy was like definitely stop by
and Rebecca knows all of them like they
were at Denise Richards wedding like
they're you know they're intertwine or
the whole thing they're local to
California it kind of made sense so I
actually don't know I'm assuming like
the Marlowe and Phaedra invites just
came from Nene I can't see Andy being
like Oh invite all the friends just
because then you have to stop it
somewhere right you know making it so
it's like it's just current housewives
makes it so it's like a complete like
finalized list obviously like people
brought other people there right what
was the dynamic between Brandi and LeAnn
because together they did take a selfie
together actually the Dallas girls were
like very so DeAndre wasn't there
carried uber wasn't there I think those
the only two that we were missing from
Dallas they were like I mean Brandi and
Stephanie I just truly really love like
they're so nice like I don't know how to
phrase this any other way they're just
like they're sweet as pie
they just want to have a good time
that's not how I view Dallas - it's like
yeah their debutante and they have to
like present themselves in a way but
they're just want to have a good time a
little bit like The OC but without the
pretension yes because also the OC is
like they could be was get really shells
though you know what I mean like so they
have to like have that sense of wealth
where's Dallas is just Dallas right but
they're also the new kid on the block so
exactly being like a little Cheyenne and
I think that maybe you know they're a
small fish in a big pond now whereas
right Dallas they're a big fish in a
small pond it's a little like Potomac
Atlanta or even like New York New Jersey
like you're kind of close in proximity
you kind of have like similar lives like
you know Potomac the only reason our
mother Dido Atlanta is like because it's
kind of like our other southern show you
know whatever and you can just kind of
like play the dynamics of it like New
Jersey is always going to be like
the trashy Aurora version of New York
right just like the OSI is gonna be that
for Beverly Hills and as it should be
that's what I like it but yeah Dallas is
kind of like its own land where they
like if were they getting in the mixer
where they kind of like all sticking
together yeah everyone at the table
likes at within their own caste like for
the most part so Dallas was actually
sitting at the opposite end of the table
from Andy and that was like where all
the Beverly Hills people were they were
just as much in the mix as anything else
okay yeah how long do you know that Andy
was having a baby before he announced it
a year so you knew before the auction
I knew yeah I knew like when we were
starting and when he was starting to
like think about it yeah it was the
biggest secret to keep for the longest
time was it really hard like were there
any moments where it almost got out yeah
I like like the only people I ever told
were my parents and my girlfriend
because that was it was affecting my
life like right you I had to tell them
and you know they're not gonna tell like
they're not gonna tell anybody and that
was it and it was really difficult
because he would call me you know and we
would talk about it I'd have to print
stuff at the office like you know we
were all of a sudden going to LA for a
few weeks and like no one really kind of
knew why and like there was a big
announcement things had to be moved like
I couldn't give people like direct
timelines for things and they were like
what's going on you can always get us
back and I'm like oh sorry just like a
lot of things up in the air so it was a
lot of playing on that and not trying to
give any sort of hint but like yeah I
almost dropped it thousands of times and
I had to like check myself that's so
honey who came up with the theme stars
born because it's brilliant I have no
idea but that was brilliant I have
literally no idea who came up with that
I mean it could have been the event
planner but it could have been Kyle who
was the event planner um this guy Edie's
rats Ian I think it was his last name he
was really really good he I have looked
at his Instagram afterwards and like the
best events ever but he worked out with
his number one event obviously athlete
obviously uh who was the most thirsty
for John Mayer Oh I mean listen I think
most women are probably thirsty for John
Mayer I would probably say like Sonja
maybe Ramona I think I saw Vicki over
there at one point like not thirsty and
then he's sort of like quick terrible
way but just definitely gravitated
immediately
towards him you know and especially he's
almost like too cool yeah you know what
do you mean lazy celebrities all the
time right exactly like it's really
nothing for them so I think the other
people who like don't get to see that
we're like all over him in the corner we
were dying laughing that is so funny so
now in hindsight did there were no
cameras there you know there's
speculation that there were even what
would you guys do with that footage you
know other than like maybe a snippet I
watch I was I'd like yeah like I guess
it could have been like part of a season
of like Beverly Hills because this was
gem there but that feels like no one was
gonna be able to be themselves you know
what at the end of the day like it was a
baby shower like I know what did it turn
out to be that way but like that was the
goal people brought gifts like right
that was the theme who was the drunkest
Lisa Rinna what she Shannon beador was
up there she I mean how was Shannon
Shannon looked good she looked really
really good she's super pretty Tamra was
gorgeous showed her boobs on radio Andy
because we were also recording for
Andy's radio channel and serious so
there's like a lot going on she looked
great she was in a jumpsuit she looked
perfect I want to keep up with Shannon
beador because you know I'm astonish
Anand Stan yeah no I love I love Shannon
this past season she lost me but I know
she's coming back no she'll be back
she's just like she goes in waves she
does she wait no and no one no one is
perfect no um what was the drama with
Beverly Hills
apparently the fight was between Doreen
and Camille confirm or deny um there was
some drama I wasn't sitting at we were
like on the side with the watch repens
live crew like we had a few of our
producers who came to LA with us we were
like kind of watching this Last Supper
go down because we wanted to see
everything the problem of the long
rectangular table is you could only see
right in front of you and this and this
you don't get to see like what's in the
wings so we really wanted to like have a
better like overall view of it they were
getting into it a little bit but I
believe you know Andy was like it's not
the place like guys like it's not the
time to be doing this and like save it
for the reunion you know what I mean
yeah favorite for when the cameras
actually are on you what was going on
between New Jersey and New York um it's
funny because I feel like the each side
sort of things that the other side is
like kind of rude but I don't know if
that's just because it's like it's
across the river you know I mean like
you're literally they were representing
their own facts
so it was really interesting I think you
know the same the same thing that people
think about Jersey and New York is true
like I think Jersey thought New York was
like kind of standoffish and like Ramona
has a tendency to be a little bit
standoffish like that's kind of that's
kind of who she is that's kind of like
her mo like she does that all the time
like that's just Ramona and I think the
Jersey girls are just like trying to
have a good time and be fun but like
even Teresa like she can be a little
standoffish because she's an OG like
she's been through it Dolores and
Margaret are literally the friendliest
most genuine people ever and they were
just coming at the table like saying all
the drama and well according to inter
I'm Dolores and Danielle had made up
yeah I think that really it's more like
a Margaret Danielle thing and I think
Dolores is like a really good buffer
because I think that she understands
Danielle's kind of crazy wild side but
but as an adult and I was like um and I
was like a mother she really understands
like Margaret was you know was a kind
person as a good soul and so she was
like the perfect buffer in between
because sometimes especially right now
it's her with Teresa she seems way more
on Danielle side that not accurate side
yeah Angela Ross is a really good person
agreed okay we'll get into New Jersey um
what was I just gonna say oh we need to
talk about the Kardashians and watch
what happened sighs okay I need to know
how how it was organized because it
wasn't promoted that much which made me
think that it was a last-minute
confirmation yeah I think it was I mean
we had always kind of planned on having
the Kardashians on it's always hard I
mean listen we've had them on before but
it's always hard to get all of them in a
room like it was like right first
interview any other their first in a
wire years so I think yeah it was
announced kind of last-minute one
because I think once you find out that
they're gonna be on the paparazzi or
just gonna be like everywhere and crazy
and absolutely nuts and like they don't
necessarily want that but yeah I think
their schedule as it was I was holding
that time soft for a while yeah yeah
understood okay and were they fighting
before because there was a weird I saw
[ __ ] like Courtney was on the outs not
that I I mean I feel like Courtney's
kind of always on the outside isn't that
like I don't wanna see the role she
plays but like that is the role she
plays more so than usual and were they
filming they were filming so people had
a signed appearance releases and like
Andy's on the show but they were filming
that as far as I saw no drama really
like it's you okay because I could
totally see it be like family fee
all the drama behind the scenes like
they got into a fight with Courtney and
then they had to go on this show and
like pretend like they're not agile
arias I love little layers are you gonna
be on Kardashians no I will not no no no
Thank You Simon release no no no I
wasn't I wasn't there for like part of
it because I was like in the back like
working and doing my own thing so I
really I couldn't even really really be
there it was like very close like most
of my most of my co-workers aren't gonna
be on it it was really just Andy got it
yeah okay yeah there I look forward to
it it was it was so good she had my hand
in the bag had some great questions yeah
and he loves them and you know he kind
of felt bad because I think he calls her
Chloe I was gonna ask you but that's
actually the proper way to pronounce it
like she has confirmed it's the proper
way to say it
it's so interesting I know because
everyone thinks I'm like Andy was just
being not Shady we're just kind of a
thirty-day I joke except certain so I
joke like it's like quirky and funny egg
if I were like Jack hey like I don't
know it was just a thing yeah but like
apparently it's correct so is there a
reason to have a joke but then I was
like you know what maybe he didn't even
realize he was saying it wrong yeah I
don't like exactly no exactly okay let's
get into some of the shows right now
because so much is going down yeah okay
New Jersey the best has ever been the
best that's ever been the best that's
ever been this past week was
particularly frustrating because I am
team Margaret until I die like on a
personal level and on the show as an
adult like she's like a role model she
really is yeah and she's so just so
burnt in her thinking yeah you know what
I mean
and it was really frustrating so you
know she's oh she does it she does it
the only reason she doesn't drink those
cuz of migraines nothing to do with like
she was an alcoholic she had problems
like it's nothing to do that she just
gets migraine so she doesn't drink so
you know she's always of like sound mind
yes oh my god I forgot about that
because so it was frustrating because
half of the group is taking the other
side and it's not even Jedi like
Jennifer I actually like her a lot I
think she was a great housewife and it's
hilarious she's great and you never know
what she's gonna say or what she's gonna
do it's like you would expect she's
never been on a girls trip before she's
gonna go on a girls trip and be on the
phone with her husband her the whole
time and be like worried about how she
behaves no yeah he goes on a girls trip
and she [ __ ] is ripping shots and
just saying does another the shot is
right in front of her she's right
where's my drink
seriously I just like her because I
never I don't know anyone like her
there's no one else like her on the show
and I think that's a really good point
because for me when I saw okay she's
like a little bit more traditionally
Turkish like you know her family
obviously like it's very involved in
that culture and that you know the
religion so I thought she was gonna be
extremely tame because I thought that
her husband like she's also representing
her husband her kids yeah what I mean
she's a first-time hasit because so
sometimes you gotta feel it out before
you can like you know but let's not
forget like she did agree to go on the
Real Housewives of New Jersey right so
like she's prepared to bring some heat
like her talking about her Palace in
Paramus like I grew up near Paramus so
like I know exactly where she's talking
about it just like hilarious like Jersey
is just so Jersey I love it I love
everything about it but she really has
brought it she's got good insults she's
got great one-liners and the good thing
about it is I think like with Margaret
being able to just like you know she
apologized immediately if she stepped
out of line talking about Jennifer's
husband and she said you know she came
back and she was like that was just
meant to hurt you for me that was an
ideal fight because it was hilarious it
was mean but it was also both sides were
I mean I was a be sad Margaret sighs
logo or started it with with the brother
and the jewelry store so like I
understood Margaret going in but like
then what Margaret said was mean so
Jennifer went mean and he was like a
perfect fight cuz it was it was all
there the money's [ __ ] thing though
like I'm sorry but Jennifer telling them
that the necklace was ugly I thought it
was just like horrible that's horrible
like it's for stuff it's a gift right
like it's not like a statement of
anything other than like hair you've
been working really hard like we love
you here sis and she's like that
necklace is ugly anyway I was like whoa
whoa so off so Margaret's like digging
in I was I was happy to see it and then
Jennifer coming back with a monkeys
house one that you [ __ ] sucked
yeah was just it was perfect it was like
what does that mean what does that mean
what is what what is any of it mean so
is it really a perfect house I decide
and then again it was like Jennifer
starts in a Patong about Margaret's mom
Margaret's my mistakes like oh limit
right exactly I'm like just like if we
can't talk about husbands and children
which is off to new jersey thing i mean
it's it should be kind of across the
board especially children in my opinion
yeah I'm your husband kind of is more
like equal on the same playing field can
choose to be on the show or not but
the Dolores is obviously don't talk
about your husband and your children
like that is Jersey like Edith like such
a code written in blood so you can't
bring up [ __ ] parents that's the same
thing same thing Knights family so
Margaret coming back at her I thought
was very warranted but they also I too
like Margaret had a pit after the fight
I was like that was kind of that was bad
and then Margaret apologized and I I
mean not that it's about me but like I
really felt like we moved on so then the
next night and Jennifer moved on and
Margaret moved on when Danielle was just
digging she was being I was inserted he
was being og Danielle stabbed like 100%
you know what to expect from Danielle
stabbed she's never gonna be the one who
like sits there and is just like watch
it all go down like she said massive
glass huge so she has hot crap and she
was so mean to Margaret and and then I'm
watching them inside and he was like -
Margaret if if you don't care what tal
size or does like why did you let her
get you so angry and it's like I just
wanted Margaret to say like I don't care
what she says or does but like that was
my reaction to someone who I don't even
care about like if someone that she
actually heard that was saying those
children like she she also said
something like off limits it wasn't like
Oh Margaret you're so ugly you should
have been like okay but saying that your
children don't want to hang out with you
and then children wasn't enough to get
her her skin she brought up
grandchildren right I was like and with
the best part about it I mean granted
and mark okay it's funny cuz Margaret
doesn't even drink so she like threw
Dolores his red wine which I also
thought was really funny but by the time
that Danielle and Jennifer and all those
people like stood up smash the glass and
we're like ready to go Margaret was like
halfway up the stairs ya know and then
the fight was like minute back Mary and
then like I love Margaret and Melissa's
friendship so much and now Jackie is a
part of it yeah and then Melissa stood
there and like went to bat for Margaret
and Teresa is just like really such a
bad judge of character
well I and I and I think that's I think
that's almost air blowing you can say to
Teresa's face like she kind of knows
that she is you know what I know yeah
it's like just know you're like you can
say that you are I don't know who made
the seating assignments like for that
dinner but it was perfectly like split
down the line Oh Jennifer Teresa and
Danielle and then like Dolores Jackie
Margaret and Melissa like it was ready
to throw down across the table yeah
it was genius it was genius it was it
was so good I was like my jaw was on the
floor it has been a while since
something has like
me so shocked it's been a great great
season of New Jersey and the reunion is
going to pack it like I promised you you
were gonna get so many good answers to
things well so we do know that Teresa
says on the reunion that if dough gets
supported she will not go with him right
my personal belief and I mean you know
this she'll just I kind of read your
face yeah yeah okay is that that is her
teeing us up and getting us comfortable
with the idea that like she is gonna
leave him in because she has a boyfriend
I mean listen that would make sense I
mean I think that you have to remember
which people should is that she's got
four daughters so whatever way is gonna
you know and those four daughters like
are affected like yeah you know they
have feelings and I think because I want
to grow up and I think we see that a lot
with them Melania milania's like whole
transformation she's clearly you know
and she's at that age where like she is
like a full-blown adult now and Melania
like that song like I will never be able
to get out of my head it is the best
like housewives not housewife song
that's come out of any franchise ever
and you know we haven't gotten a song in
a really long time we have it it's been
a minute and we really we deserve it we
didn't deserve it Melania is giving only
so much Erika Jayne can do great she
can't hold the entire like fork down for
everyone and like melissa hasn't come
out like in a while with a song on
display was amazing but you could really
see that and so we think no matter what
Theresa is always gonna put her girls
first and she's gonna do the right thing
by leaking whatever she needs to leak to
make it easier for her girls I will say
that she's a really really good mom yes
yeah so whatever protects them whatever
is good for them she's gonna think of
them first okay next up yeah the Beverly
Hills trailer Beverly Hills is
premiering next week and it can't come
soon enough
yeah I'm watching the first episode
today because I missed it when I was in
LA because I was traveling I couldn't
have time someone watch the first
episodes oh my god but then how are you
know I guess you could watch all the
episodes whenever you want like I would
ask you something throws up somebody
then I can't wait that one for the
second episode right exact I need to
know what's going on what the [ __ ] is
going on with Lisa Vanderpump is she a
kinda member you know I can't tell you
anything okay what's gonna happen
because then you're not like you don't
want to know what you think that you
want to know Jackie but you don't know I
you I did you're gonna see her like
you're gonna see Lisa like she's around
she's in the ether but something went
down and unfold we all see it unfold and
now let me ask you I'll reposition my
question because something that we
talked about is that she will always be
tethered to Bravo her position as a
housewife is interesting because she
will always be tethered to Bravo by
Vanderpump rules now how much of her
role on on Beverly Hills is related to
the fact that Vanderpump worlds are they
separate entities or do someone
constantly have something to do with the
other there are separate entities you
know she's an executive producer and
obviously like talent on Vanderpump
rules cuz she's you know she obviously
plays like the matriarch of everything
but also the matriarch of the staff so
she really does run that you know she
gets paid to be the executive producer
on the show she has an opinion on it but
it is entirely separate similar
production company is similar people
working on both but not like it's
entirely different okay so there could
be one without the other
yeah and as you know like there was some
crossover like sometimes I'll have like
Stassi and like Kristen like serve a
party at Kyle Richards house and like
Teddy's brother and Brandi clans okay I
don't think when she was being
introduced on the show so there was
crossover but now Vanderpump rules as
its own beast like in its own light -
that - yeah it's its own entity
okay Teddy's brother is he gonna be was
that us them getting us ready for him to
be on the cast when he had that
interview to be a busboy or a barback um
Teddy's brother Teddy Mellencamp's
brother um was on Vanderpump rules
yeah I don't think that was like like a
I think it was just like a really nice
crossover I don't think that was like
pretty sure debate can be like his own
talking head as I know okay cool I
appreciate it
yeah yeah I mean I was thinking Ariana's
brother for a second no that's a
separate name with a Billy leave yeah
that's why I was gonna confuse that it's
a separate thing okay so now we know
from the trailer and from Instagram that
Doreen and LBP have had a falling-out
yeah the press said it was because of a
rescue dog that brought home that wasn't
getting along well with her kids so she
brought it to a shelter which was just
like Bad News Bears for LBP
yeah is this really the central fight I
mean I think that's one of I think first
off we all know that LVP really cares
about animals like and who does it right
right obviously Doritos as well like
there's not like
the dog was tortured and I don't want to
like spread tear on one of the ASPCA
like come after us in any sort of way or
PETA but I definitely think like that
was the heart of of what's going down
okay
ya know what sometimes plays a role you
read things in the news you're like they
don't know what's going no it plays a
role I mean they don't know what's going
on but I think like listen that means
they'll be at restaurants and no filming
and like you could easily be sitting
next to them like it's not like it this
happens on like a stage like this is
happening in real life people can see it
it's just that the way that it's like
produced and how we kind of go through
it might be different than what you
think you saw exactly yes cuz we did see
them in the Bahamas having what looked
to me like the best trip ever
yeah in derice bathing suits which are
the cutest things ever obsessed with
Beverly Beach not that I own anything
but like that's very PK is a
controversial figure
he was dead-on about really neat dead-on
about Beverly Beach beach and it's like
the best name cuz it does sound like a
fictional place you just want to go no
it's like perfect health
remember that back in the day of course
it's like what fire festival should have
been right yeah oh my god totally she
could start doing festivals Beverly
Beach festivals um so they went to the
hummus yeah looked lit and now we're
seeing more of a friendship between
Erika Jayne Murray yep Lisa like which
is the crew that that I've eaten in my
life and Erika Jayne was amazing at the
shower just like she turned up she was
great I mean she didn't even I thought
she was gonna like saying like Kyle
really I was hoping it was but she's
that kind of like she's introvert like
she's she's shy
no she's definitely Shire she remembers
everyone his name and she's a super
she's a professional but she's not like
everyone like would compare to I think
was drag queen is you know what yeah
like really in your face and super
makeup din like uh like a pop star like
she's not like that at all she's pretty
like reserved I feel like she really is
Hannah Montana like when she's being
Miley Stewart like she and she's being
mrs. Girardi yeah she is buttoned up and
then when she's being Erika Jayne the
pretty mess like yup she'll bring it all
out but she's not gonna just do that at
the palm at a baby shower when she
showed up in her RT that's what that's I
think that's a really good point i think
i think her Erika Jayne is like is like
the villain to her normal self it's like
that's her creative outlet yeah moment
in time for 10% of her life and the rest
of her she's a mom she's like a 27 year
old kid like she's got a real wife very
cute yeah
would you the trailer
the trailers obviously look great Oh
ways Congrats to your editing team but
would you say like this season of
Beverly Hills is as like on par with
this season of Jersey like best in a
while oh yeah I would probably I mean
that's what I've heard
obviously I haven't seen the first
episode yet I'm gonna say that with like
a caveat asterisk asterisk for when I
heard from Andy though at all my
co-workers this is like such an amazing
season like Jenice is awesome she's a
really good addition to the entire group
okay especially with the whole like the
LVP controversy I just think this is
gonna be like it's not gonna be as you
know I mean the fights are different
right the fights on Jersey are different
than Beverly Hills so I can't like
compare it oranges to oranges but it's
good okay gonna like it the glitz and
the glam definitely like and I don't
know if you know but Claudia and I have
been waiting for the reckoning of LBP
since I would say she brought the
magazines on the trip and yeah I just
scream um tried to blame Brandi I think
this is your voodoo doll magic like
coming into life or it's like all those
like LVP like dolls you've been stabbing
in the back of your closet for ten years
like maybe this is justice for the oshri
sisters and this is dresses for an event
oh yeah this is justice but he's like
she's waiting in no way he's like
Twitter like totally yes salivating yeah
salivating and ready for this okay Dan
upon paroles yeah he's so good I mean
every season is so good season this is
Jeff a this jaw blaze up oh my god James
Kennedy what do you think of Raquel I
don't know in her seat yeah because I'm
of two minds like obviously it's easy to
be like really she's dumb how does she
not see nice I believe she sees it and
she's being done in a lot of respects
but I also think we've seen a lot of the
other girls be in her position before
and make equally bad choices
yep and I think a part of her like what
like you know she's missin OMA like
being a reality star isn't a far cry and
she wants you know to be on the show and
James is her meal ticket and so she's
gonna try and make it work as much as
she can wait I think that I think that
James cheating like him trying to hide
that he cheated is like the lamest thing
ever like we all know it like no I mean
awhile I said it best I think it was
Lala who was like your boyfriend's not
Johnny Depp sweetie like no one's lying
to say that they slept with him like if
they slept with him it's because they're
like a embarrass or be
want to give you the truth like what
happened right like I think it was Lala
who said that works amazing like of
course I'll say that did you watch the
episode I think it was most recent where
they're in that roller rink yes okay so
they're dressed as like 80s in the
roller rink and I like how while those
like combinations with James and she's
like you know I will get back on track
and at the end she's just like I'm sorry
I called you dumb Raquel and like they
was walk to make it sorry I called you
dumb you're welcome yeah oh I love Lalo
so much I love her we we need more of
her we need more of her she's I mean
listen she's getting there right cuz her
first season everyone thought she was
like oh she's gonna sleep with Jax and
then she was like and no honey I'm not
gonna do anything like I've got my own
thing I've got my own man like the whole
already on a drama that's going on with
her right now she's just one of my
favorite people and she's genuinely just
so nice and just so beautiful um I think
we're Kelly I think you're right about
the meal ticket and I think it's really
easy I think a lot of people do this and
they don't admit it so I'm kind of happy
that at least Raquel is like you know
she's consistent
yeah but I think to say that like she
doesn't know if James cheated like don't
be dumb like it's okay to listen
everyone has their own rules but first
you like accept and he needs to and you
should like be concerned that he's not
being honest with you it's okay to still
stay with someone after they cheat like
this happens all the time and some
people have open relationships and I
don't think that we could just judge
other people's relationships we don't
know what happens behind closed doors
but I think that her main concern should
be the fact that James is like kind of
embarrassing her yeah and if he just
came forward and was honest with her
like Jax eventually did with Brittany
and faith like that made me at least
more believable in the couple yeah at
least we can like start from scratch and
and build back up right exactly like
you're making it so he can just avoid it
the rest of his life right and I think
James has like a few decent qualities
like he pays for his whole family and
any rock he'll like when something bad
goes down she just focuses on that she's
like James is a good guy he's eating
like a queen right yeah and but it's
like okay maybe 1% of the time like he's
decent but you have to also recognize
just the night exactly at the time
exactly correct but then I also think
that James recognizes that his meal
ticket is the show and being a villain
and you know if he's not he doesn't have
that real like familial friendship with
the rest of the group yeah so unless
he's making waves he's kind of
irrelevant
yeah he's not gonna be like the main guy
that people want to see you
I'm gonna be like an automatic invite
like Stassi Katie Kristen Jax Tom Tom
like Ariana they're all friends of each
other their boyfriends are like friends
they've updated each other you know and
if they're older kind of on the outside
yeah
Jax is almost 40 and James is like in
his mid-20s like there's a huge
difference in their granted stassi's my
Archie's 30 like you know they
definitely have the range but like he's
he's much younger than the rest of the
cast it does seem like that you know
what I mean he could learn from Lala
like she's younger and she's not in that
and she has a boyfriend she's not
drinking yeah you know like he's but
it's clear that he has and I heard some
things about him this weekend that Super
Bowl like oh yeah we're he's drinking on
the show i watch rivers live yeah are
you gonna drink and he's like yellow the
Moscow Mule we're like what yeah so it's
when you know that now it's why I get
back it's like but I know you didn't
stick to this exactly okay and then the
last thing we're talking about it's in
New York trailer another just wonderful
trailer yes what seems to be an
incredible season it's going to be
incredible a lot of drama is going down
but like a lot of good I would say like
mending happens with the group as well
like everyone's kind of got their own
stone your store story but Sonja I think
especially from last season and coming
off of it I thought that was Sonja's
like adult season last year like not
that she was like a child I just thought
that she was like a different person
like she felt lighter
she felt like more loving like she sold
her townhouse like she was moving on she
was being independent so I really think
it's like Sonja's trajectory that were
gonna really I love that and I hope that
Bethenny supports her because if
Bethenny says one mean word to Sonja I'm
done with her
after what Sonja did for her last season
I don't think she's going to though
because I feel like Betty know right now
like has Sonya on her side along with
LuAnn and we're kind of like picking up
from where the reunion left and if you
remember like how the reunion left like
Dorinda and her like apologized and like
maybe made amends maybe not I don't know
but I think like Ramona and Bethenny
still have their kind of words with each
other so I really feel like it's LuAnn
Sonja and Bethenny that are like the
core group right now love it yeah do
that for it exciting plus like we
haven't done it like so much stuff has
happened that you've got about Assad I
know it's so sad but Bethenny has a new
man in her life or men yes she's got a
new boyfriend I think but Bethenny's
really good it like I mean granted she
has a daughter and like Jason hi
be like that whole thing that went down
like I'm sure she has to protect you
know Bryn in so many different ways so I
don't really I don't really know the
truth and sell like see it on camera
right I really can't say like she could
be lying about everything to protect her
daughter even still it's like am i see
on camera I'm like so is she with Dennis
or not like we're together and they
weren't together they were like good
friends I'm like okay like obviously
when that went down and he died like she
was utterly just devastated and rocked
and you know we're definitely gonna see
some of that this season I think and
yeah the aftermath of all of that
because that was a serious thing that
happened you know what I mean like
people do have died like on the show
before like friends with people on the
show and like you can really see
people's reaction I actually think
that's what's the good thing about the
show you know what I mean it helps other
people sort of deal with it and feel
like hey it's not just me like famous
people and reality stars and rich people
like have the same problem sometimes
yeah yeah Mo Money mo problems two more
questions Jill Zarin yeah is she just
being teased per usual she's been in the
past three trailers like I'm sure she'll
show up yes I'll show up as I show up
she'll be around I mean I think this is
a really good test to see like how she
interacts with the ladies you know you
can't just throw anybody not the cheese
random but you could just door someone
into the ring again you know what I mean
like you has to make cohesive sense it
has to be storylines there has to be
something to follow it can't just be
like five of you and then like one of
you was over here and you can't hang out
with anyone right so let's see how she
kind of weeps at the group TBD
last question yeah because OC starts
filming next week last we heard from
them Kelly dad had said that she would
not return to the show with Nikki is on
yeah who's on I can't say for sure I
know who's on I can't I will I will
leave that to you to guess but let's
just say you know it's it's um it's a
good it's a it's like my favorite people
it's a good cast it's good and
interesting it has judging by the baby
shower Vicky was there and Kelly wasn't
that's true however judging by last
season Kelly needs for the show sake
Kelly is the best housewife on that show
Kelly laughing at Julie's like like like
a theater recital was hands-down my
favorite house-sized moment like just my
favorite moment of all time
she is so epic and so I I don't think
they'll ever get rid of Vicky because
she's the og not only of the OC but of
the franchise is the first housewife she
is it's so annoying yes
but you know sometimes like if you have
to say goodbye but anyways I think maybe
they're both on and like Kelly got a
huge raise to just eat it maybe that's
true maybe that's true I know it serves
it may be Jackie's right well we we
won't know until it comes as long as
Kelly's there I don't get her feet
viki's they're not like we just need
Kelly and Shannon and Tamra and I can't
believe I'm here shamera
broke up I'm here for Howard they at the
baby shower they were actually really
good think they were hanging down on
each other they were fine okay we're
fine totally fine
like they were Vicki and Shannon and
tres amigas the tres amigos were there
drinking their tequila living and loving
life breaking feet breaking feet I mean
Kyle was doing splits on the table like
it was a lot amazing yeah thank you so
much for one being here and breaking it
all down and joining me for the premium
content that you shared with the entire
world of the baby shower like that was
my most premium that was your most that
was my high-end premium content premium
peak baby honestly anyone's most premium
like not only be everyone like we the
toasters there was a thread in the
toasters like what you would have done
to be a fly on the wall like given Simon
Callow a job yeah to be a fly on the
wall baby shower and like because of you
we were almost there and we didn't have
to write I mean I didn't tag anyone like
I just needed the video to be like this
speaks for itself like I didn't have one
drink and I was like this is through my
eyes no you're like I'm witnessing
history and I'm a documentarian history
is going to be televised amen you're a
documentarian thanks for being here I
always work you to the bone an hour and
a half long show yeah thank you to the
toasters that's toasters thanks to super
bowl and we will see you tomorrow
Claudia we'll be back with the regular
scheduled programming show and if for
some reason you haven't seen any of the
baby shower footage it's all my
highlights at carpe Darin on Instagram
how many followers did you get that day
I got like four thousand it's like from
that like my friends were like tracking
it like the Doppler radar and I was like
guys I see that is so funny I want more
and more and more and more and more so
check them out of my highlights icarver
darren yeah it is it worth year it's
epic thank you for making it a highlight
and thank you for being here we love
having you I love being here I'll come
back any time
yes I'm gonna need you back because now
that Beverly Hills in New York are
popping off like I'm gonna need oh yeah
we hope you figure out how I feel about
it
yeah I'm right now only new Oh New
Jersey in Atlanta are on you know I just
can't can't keep up with that Lana
and I recognize that it's the best
franchise it is and I don't know why I
can't keep its because there's so much
history and I refuse to watch any
seasons without having rewatch all the
old ones and unfortunately I'm a busy
woman who's getting married soon and
like really [ __ ] chefs I know next
time I see you're gonna be a berry dwarf
that's gonna be very exciting very
exciting that's so crazy
okay I love you thank you so much you're
welcome guys have a great day
you